all i know is i got pruned and i woke up
here and now i'm surrounded by variants
of myself
plus an alligator which i'm heartbroken
to report i didn't even find all that
strange
okay fine willing to accept that we're
in a shark tank goliath is the shark
oh there's no such thing as an alligator
tank besides it's a better metaphor yes
but if you thought of using a temp pad
oh the one thing that could easily get
us out of here yes
they're all over the place right guys
fine so after i vanquished captain
america
i claimed my prize all six infinity
stones
that's alligator for growling and seeing
liar
i'm going to kill eliath and i could use
all the help i could get
[Laughter]
well at least my nexus event wasn't
eating the wrong neighbor's cat
why the hell is there an alligator in
here
it also doesn't mean it's good
see he's on board he's praying thinks
we're going to die
how best to put this uh us as a child
us in the future and us as uh
uh an alligator yes we're gonna kill
goliath oh my god that was your plan
yeah and you all went along with it i
was i was having my doubts
all right no i don't remember an
alligator
i mean who's to say he's even a low-key
variant he's green isn't he
the long con of course that just makes
him more likely to be a loki
i hope they know what they're doing